Hey youtubers it's Charlie and this week's
Teen Wolf is a Super Powered Time Bomb just
waiting to go off. And even though the cast
and crew are on Vacation, they were tweeting
a bunch of funny behind the scenes facts from
the episode. And just a reminder, Comic Con
is this week, the Teen Wolf Panel is on Thursday.
Hello any new people, if you're just now finding
me I do weekly Teen Wolf videos, be sure to
subscribe to get everything. If you really
want me to upload the comic con panel you
can vote in my strawpoll. There's a link for
that in the description.
So episode 5 had a few pretty amazing WTFs
so I'm going to start with my top 5 then do
my review and then explain my comic con giveaway.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven't seen it yet. I'll wait just a sec.
Okay here we go.
Number 5 - Derek is Losing his powers
They still haven't explained what it is that
Kate took other than to say it's his "True
Essence". The way I'm thinking about it in
my head is that she just took his Wolf Mojo.
Like the wolf part of his soul. I have a few
theories about why that is, mostly involving
a lot of double crosses and the true identity
of the benefactor.
I think based on Derek's progression, his
Wolf Tank will be empty way before the season
finale. Like he'll be a normal person sometime
in the next 4 episodes. What would he even
do with himself then? He'd have to get a real
job, especially if they can't get their families
money back. And he'd be extra vulnerable to
attack.
I think it's more likely that he would team
up with Chris Argent and try to Hunt down
supernatural creatures and help them, rather
than kill them like the Calaveras. It would
be like the Winchester Brothers Teen Wolf
Edition.
If they made a spin off like that, would you
guys watch it?
Number 4 - Lydia and Malia decode the next
part of the list
Did anyone else feel like they totally reversed
roles. Like Malia was the one flipping out
last week and Lydia was the voice of reason,
and this week Lydia completely lost her mind
staring at that record player all weekend
and Malia was the normal one.
On top of that, does anyone notice that each
episode Malia is starting to look more and
more like a normal teenage girl. Like fixing
her hair and wearing makeup, some of her reactions
were still very much coyote adorable. Like
almost resting her head on Lydia's shoulder
in the art studio.
Anyone who has owned a big dog will understand.
They stand behind you when you're sitting
down and just stick their heads out right
in your face. It's pretty funny.
The real WTF came later when Lydia lost it
all over Meredith. Pretty much everyone in
the episode was an IED just waiting to explode.
Number 3 - Everyone Is An Improvised Explosive
Device
That's what IED stands for in case you weren't
sure. In the episode they were using it as
a metaphor for Liam's Intermittent Explosive
Disorder. But when you hear someone say IED,
they're usually referring to a dirty bomb.
A dirty bomb is typically something you find
in overseas urban combat. Like the Iraq war
or Afghanistan.
So the idea of a bomb going off informed all
the different plot points as well as the character
arcs. Of all the episodes so far I feel like
the writing in this one was the best. The
more you can tie things in the episode to
the main theme, the stronger the whole episode
is.
Like Lydia blowing up in Meredith's face,
Garrett blowing up on the lacrosse field or
Liam blowing up in everyone's face.
The problem is that not all of those explosive
devices or people can be cured with Anti Psychotic
meds.
I love how Parrish kind of became the Jeremy
Renner character from Hurt Locker. Fun Fact:
That was the part that got Jeremy Renner hired
as Hawkeye in all the Marvel films.
Parrish is a whole other story, but a big
part of the IED plot was disarming the people
bombs. Parrish kind of disarmed Lydia but
the real callback was Scott and Stiles throwing
Liam in the shower. That's a nice callback
to Scott getting thrown in the shower when
he first started freaking out in season 1
and in the flashback where Peter threw Derek
in the shower after the basketball game when
he was a freshman.
The big thing we learn from this I think is
that none of the male characters are allowed
to be normal in the locker room. It's like
it's a requirement they have a freakout in
there.
Number 2 - CSI Teen Wolf
Tyler Posey was talking about the CSI style
scenes Stiles had saying that their editor,
the person who edits Teen Wolf used to edit
for CSI. And they have a very particular way
they cut the scenes when characters are figuring
out clues. So they called Stiles scenes CSI
Teen Wolf.
First off, the scenes looked beautiful from
a cinematography perspective, but two did
you notice all the red tape Stiles was using?
It was a nice callback to all his red markers
from season 3 and Malia's Red Markers this
season.
At this point I feel like Red has become the
color for WTF on the show. Anytime there's
a freakout or you're talking about murder
or something awful is happening, the color
red is invoked either visually or metaphorically.
For instance, the deadpool chart, full of
red, Lydia's freaky record player, Red. And
anytime Scott loses his shit on someone his
eyes glow alpha Red.
Keep your eyes peeled for Red in next week's
episode. I'll bet that anytime something crazy
happens, red will be somewhere in the frame.
and my Number 1 WTF Moment - Parrish is On
The List
I think we all kind of suspected something
was up with him. He's always been waay too
cool about Lydia's supernatural status and
all the crazy Beacon Hills stuff that has
happened.
Just because he's on the list doesn't guarantee
he's a Werewolf, but what else do you think
he could be? The show has opened up the mythology
a lot every year. So it's possible he could
be something we haven't seen yet.
Kira is a Thunder Kitsune and can absorb electrical
energy, if Parrish did Bomb Disposal during
the war in Afghanistan, maybe his abilities
have something to do with absorbing damage
or seeing how things work?
If you had a supernatural ability to look
for clues, becoming a deputy sheriff would
be an appropriate career path. He said he
was drawn to beacon hills, so maybe he's a
banshee too and just has a WTF radar like
Lydia.
I think the show is 'shipping him with Lydia
anyway, so I'll bet he joins the pack unofficially
by the end of the season, if he survives.
Which I hope he does. I like him a lot more
this season.
And it wasn't one of my favorites, but the
Calaveras showing up at the end got me thinking
about who the Benefactor might be. They said
that Braeden had gone missing, she was looking
for Kate, but what if she's in on the Deadpool
plot.
I thought that Peter might be behind it all,
or at least the Kate part. Using it secretly
as a way to steal Derek's power. I could see
him sacrificing all that money and letting
all those people die just to get his Alpha
powers back. But that seems a little too complicated.
I find that the real solutions tend to be
a lot simpler. But the benefactor knew that
Liam had just been turned into a werewolf.
And it has to be someone who knew Aiden and
Allison. I'm starting to think it's someone
who's inside the pack or was in the pack.
That technically includes Peter and Braeden
but it could also include Ethan and Isaac
who we haven't seen yet this season.
So if you want to theorycraft, just keep it
to people close to the pack. You remember
that old saying that most robberies are 'inside
jobs'.
My craziest theory is that it's Parrish. He
has knowledge of explosives, like the one
that disarmed Kate and Derek in the vault.
But let me know what your theories are?
I wouldn't be surprised to learn that Peter
or Parrish were working with Kate or Braeden.
Those four characters are like the highest
on my watch list.
Overall the episode was a solid B plus, I
felt like there were two clear parts to the
story. There was pre-lacrosse, then Lacrosse.
Everything before lacrosse was finding out
where the IED bomb was, represented by Garrett.
Once they found out where he was, the Lacrosse
half of the episode began and it was all about
them waiting for the bomb to go off. The wolfsbane
bomb.
You could even make it simpler than that.
It was like the whole episode was about finding
a bunch of different bombs and disarming them.
Sometimes those bombs were people inside the
pack, sometimes they were other people like
Garrett and Violet and sometimes they were
actual bombs, like Parrish in the flashback.
The other real points of interest was the
talk going on around the episode, Jeff Davis
took over the Teen Wolf twitter account and
Tyler posey and the rest of the cast were
live tweeting funny stuff while it was happening.
Tyler's favorite Derek Scott moment ever was
when Derek was congratulating him in the locker
room. And Jeff Davis posted a picture of them
making Stiles opening title sequence scene.
With all the red tape. This is what it looks
like when they're shooting it. Isn't that
crazy. All that time for just a few seconds
of footage.
The last big about the episode I'll say is
that the last name on the list, the one they
have to unlock. it's probably someone who
was in the pack but has died. That could be
Jackson, or any of the dead Hale's. It seems
like it's all a vendetta killing in reaction
to the deaths of those keyword characters,
like Allison and Aiden.
In case you didn't see, I am running a Teen
Wolf Comic Con giveaway. All you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a comment.
I'll be picking a random person from the comments
next week. The Panel is Thursday. Let me know
if you want me to upload highlights from it.
I'm making a comic con video playlist for
all the comic con stuff I'm doing. Here's
a link to those videos. I'll be adding stuff
throughout the week. And you can click here
for my episode 4 video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!